So Paul, why is persistence important
and how many prototypes can you
expect to make if you're actually
building out an app from scratch?
>> A lot.
Way more than you think you should or
than you think is at all reasonable.
Your trash can should be full by
the end of the week, every single week.
I'm not talking about full blown
interactive JavaScript prototypes.
That's going to take a lot longer.
I'm talking about sketch prototypes.
When you start,
you want to focus on iterating quickly
in the cheapest possible medium.
And often that can be crayons, right?
You go out to a, actually, every time
I go out to a restaurant, I ask for
a kids menu and crayons, if I see them.
So that if I have an idea or
I want to jot something down or
whatever I have pen and
paper there and I can sketch it out.
>> Right.
>> There are a couple different iPhone
apps if you're doing mobile development
that let's you turn sketches very
quickly into kind of
mock interact prototypes.
>> Right.
>> But
it works perfectly
fine just to sit there,
and actually move the paper around to
create the impression of interactivity.
>> Right.
>> And
interactive prototypes are great
because you can make them super, super,
super fast and
you can make them super quickly.
Sketching out ten prototypes,
ten full flows throuo your app should
take you no more than an hour or two.
And then you take those prototypes
around to five different people in your
office and walk them through each one.
And now you have an amazing amount
of user testing data that's going to
be invaluable as you start to move
into interactive prototypes or
like click-through prototypes or
full JavaScript interactive prototypes.
>> And as time goes on you'll get
faster at building these prototypes and
at finding users to test with.
>> Exactly, yeah.
As you go on, one, you'll get better
at knowing which interactions or
how to represent interactions in paper.
You'll get better with your tools,
your interactive click-through tools.
You'll get, if you start coding,
better at JavaScript,
or better at talking to
the developers who are actually
building the prototype about which
things matter, to speed that up.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And as you get better at that,
of course, you get faster.
And so you can really tear
through prototypes and
just throw them out at the end.
So one thing that's really important to
remember about these paper prototypes
and interact prototypes is that
the first times that you make them,
you're going to look at them and
you're going to say,
this sucks, this is terrible.
This is not at the right solution,
and that's fine.
That's absolutely perfect.
Your goal is not to find
the right solution the first time,
your goal is to iterate lots and lots
and lots and lots and lots and lots and
lots and lots and lots and lots of times
and eventually find the best solution.
Separate from that, as a designer, as
a prototyper yourself, you're going to
look at this and say, this is not
the best thing that I could've made.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Your craft will not be very good.
That's fine.
You're going to suck at this for
a long time, before you're good at it.
>> Right.
>> That's part of doing this.
And because you're doing so
many of these,
you're going to get better really fast.
And so the best thing that you
can do is just keep going.
Just keep making prototypes,
keep sketching,
keep making interactive prototypes.
>> Mm-hm.
>> You will get faster,
you will get better, it will get easier.
Just keep going.